what's up guys bang bang the news broke
that the united states is going to take
7 billion from the afghanistan central
bank that we have in our possession
we're going to split it up between 9 11
victims and humanitarian aid for
afghanistan this is pretty crazy because
now all of a sudden we're entering a
very very weird world this is
unprecedented action where the united
states is going to take the central bank
reserves of a different country and we
basically are just going to take it and
do whatever we want with it now there's
a lot of nuance here there's obviously
geopolitical strategy at play there's
national security etc but i think again
this just goes to show not your keys not
your coins when it comes to bitcoin but
also not your gold not your dollars not
your money and the people of afghanistan
that's their money they're getting a
front row seat to the problems that
arise in sovereignty so ultimately i
think that this is just another example
of what is likely to transpire over the
next couple of years as more and more
people learn about bitcoin not your keys
not your coin a decentralized digital
currency ends up showing that you always
keep sovereignty of your own financial
assets it'll take a while for nation
states to get in on the game but
individuals institutions and of course
the financial organizations they're all
learning about this and eventually
nation states will just be the next
cohort to adopt bitcoin